[Music]
hold on tight turn up the elevator music
and get ready for a whole new mode of
space exploration
forget rocket launches we already use
elevators to bring us to extreme Heights
in our tallest buildings so why can't
they take us just a little further into
space but wait how much would that cost
do we even have the kind of technology
needed to make that possible and what
would we gain by building a space
elevator this is what if and here's what
would happen if we built an elevator to
space would you like to take a cheap
vacation to space well you might be in
luck because although the construction
of a space elevator would be incredibly
expensive eventually it would make space
travel much more affordable and open up
a world of opportunities but scientists
tell us that there would also be a slew
of technological logistical and
political hurdles to overcome would it
even be worth it every elevator needs a
starting point and a destination so to
make our space elevator the first thing
we'd need to do is launch a satellite or
destination way up into the sky but how
tall would our lifts need to be well as
of right now the tallest structure we've
ever built is the Burj Khalifa in Dubai
which stands at eight hundred and twenty
nine point eight meters in order to
create a successful space elevator it
would have to be at least thirty-five
thousand seven hundred and eighty-six
kilometers tall that's more than 40
thousand times taller than anything
we've ever built besides the obvious
necessity of leaving our atmosphere the
reason the space elevator would have to
be so tall is to reach something called
geostationary orbit this is the point
where an object's natural orbit exactly
matches the speed of rotation of the
earth below it reaching this orbit would
ensure that our elevator shaft always
remains straight and our destination
never moves relative to where we
launched from our next step would be to
lower a cable or ribbon from the
satellite and attach it to our starting
point back on earth clamp to the cable
would be a form of elevator car that
would carry people or cargo up and down
if we can successfully pull this off it
would completely revolutionize space
exploration right now our primary means
of getting to space are rockets and
Rockets are expensive at current prices
it costs about 20 thousand dollars to
send one kilogram into space to put it
in perspective that means approximately
1.3 million dollars to send an average
human up there after construction the
cost of sending one kilogram into space
with a space elevator would be reduced
to just $200 if we set up a space
station at the top of the elevator we'll
be able to launch all our missions from
there and not have to worry about the
costs that are usually involved with
propelling out of our atmosphere on top
of easy traveling a space elevator would
also open up some new energy
possibilities if we place giant solar
panels along our ribbon they could
collect far more energy than panels on
earth and radiate it back at low cost
this all sounds good in theory but it
also comes with a lot of obstacles the
main one is the ribbon that connects it
all it has to be light affordable and
more stable than any material we can
produce right now if we don't wait for
the right material our ribbon could snap
and that would be very dangerous if it
breaks near the base the force applied
to the satellite will cause the whole
thing to rise into space and if it snaps
near the top the ribbon will fall
wrapping around the world and creating
dangerous space debris
so as tempting as it may be to go all in
on the space elevator right now maybe
we'd best wait until we're able to do it
right in the meantime we could always
try it on the moon first but that's a
topic for another what is
[Music]